je ne demande pas d'argent et je demande
simplement du respect pour voir pour moi
et tous les joueurs qui font des
sacrifices tous les jours
[Musique]
demanda-t-il juste du respect c'est tout
que ses propos en poupe beaucoup de mots
pour beaucoup de joueurs pour tes propos
il avait dit que ce n'est pas tout le
monde qui tenait à fond que ce n'était
pas tout le monde qui était
professionnel et moi je sais vraiment
ces propos là qui m'ont touché
je me suis senti vraiment insulté parce
que j'ai sacrifié beaucoup de choses
dans ma famille vraiment vraiment
beaucoup et que beaucoup de joueurs
aussi sont dans la même réalité qu'eux -
est en fait tout ce que je voulais je
voulais je voulais montrer c'était la
réalité de d'un jour de tennis en dehors
du dr matthew crippen super forme ce
moment quelqu'un panis et unlimited 2
minimum pour encore une maille participe
une fois de slam single you and i know
in africa athlètes ce budget à limeil
crise wayne tristepin quelqu'un avait
des centaines de joueurs qui étaient
dans la même situation que moi comment
tu ne sais vraiment pour donner pour
donner un peu de bois et honnêtement je
m'attendais pas du tout à cette raison
j'ai eu l'honneur d'avoir venus williams
qui a commenté bongo pour moi ça m'a
touché mais vraiment bougé ni curieuse
qui m'a encouragé dans plein d'autres
grands joueurs ça fait vraiment vraiment
vraiment chaud au coeur de savoir donc
ça nous sommes entendus même aux narines
dominique moisi de leicester avec toi
c'est surtout impressionné l'entraîneur
physiothérapie et mentale coach atrébate
staff allemand j'espère que les
instances fédérales nationales
internationales à l'atp et la wta
rennes quand conscience que le système
ne fonctionne pas et que qu'il est
peut-être temps de changer certaines
choses deviennent trop sinueuse mike
hayes do you always on my best to do
whatever it takes to fall che d'europe
ce people had managing despite de la caf
a vraiment qu'ils vont prendre
conscience de la réalité de ce qui se
passe réellement en dehors du top 100
parce que dans tous les bons coups que
ces joueurs là il n'y aurait pas deux il
n'y aurait pas de classement il n'y
aurait pas il n'y aurait pas un numéro
un mondial et aline aurait enfin cette
100e mondiale il fait ce qui fait du
tennis tennis étaient vraiment tous les
joueurs que ça soit le top 100 ou le top
1000 un style rock to achieve the bike
hailwood maïs collègue martin family
life my brain mind the lights busby
holidays mike rôle est aussi en train de
vivre un moment de crise il faut pas
l'oublier
je pense qu'avant d'être un dieu à nice
pour égoïste il faut savoir être
solidaire
il ne s'agit pas que du sport là c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui touche le
monde entier
je pense que c'est très important d'être
solidaires dans dansé pendant cette
période là
[Musique]